[Music]
look and Miley Cyrus's that yoga pose
whoa you don't understand the high jinks
that ensued once we saw that picture
because Nancy O'Dell
went full Miley she flashed all the way
back to high school at the Coastal
Academy in Myrtle Beach South Carolina
look at her and then the shell Turner
trying to hit in the mix ride you try no
how would a half mile I went full Miley
okay because we love when Miley takes
everything to the extreme so it's no
surprise that she is all in on the voice
I'm gonna win so I'm really excited to
win the voice I wanted to be on the
voice as a coach after I mentored last
time I don't think enough people know
that how real the voice actually is I
mean I kind of am used to things in this
industry not always being what they seem
especially when you watch things on TV
and this is what it seems like Miley's
ready to throw down for season 11 she's
loving being one of two female coaches a
first for the show the world likes to
make this like girl girl catfight
scenario we're so not those girls that's
actually Blake and Adam what Coach Miley
got in her playbook
first dressed to distract I don't
actually love attention on me I think
style can be something that can make you
feel comfortable it's something to kind
of not maybe just have everyone staring
into your soul that's like giving them
something to look at so I would like to
focus on people's style even if that has
nothin it's totally different from mine
number two be a musical chameleon with
me I don't think there's necessarily
that kind of like genre wall I think if
we do country because of my background
you could want to be on my team like
maybe I can come out and steal some of
Adams teams just to bug him then also
I'm a sucker for like any sort of ballad
and especially a piano ballad so I don't
want to go against Alesha but got to and
finally number three use what you've got
the Internet's your best friend and then
you can put out something virally if you
don't have to wait for these people in
suits to tell you you're good enough you
can you can do it